the next season of apex legends is
introducing a new mode and a new legend
dark souls servers have been shut down
due to a really dangerous exploit and
more
defiance is the name of the next season
of apex legends and it's bringing us a
whole lot of new stuff in the most
recent stories from the outlands it is
confirmed that mad maggie is not only
making her return after putting us
through ring hell a few seasons ago but
she's actually joining the apex games as
the next playable legend we learned that
this is her punishment for betraying the
syndicate treaty when she attacked
king's canyon during fuse's introduction
ceremony nothing has been confirmed
about her kit just yet but there is some
character arn out in the wild showing
her with a whip and shield i'm
definitely getting some brigitta vibes
from overwatch already but we're gonna
have to wait and see aside from a new
legend we're also getting a brand new
game mode that feels heavily inspired by
titanfall's hardpoint mode but with a
few more players the new control mode
will be an ltm during the first three
weeks of the new season you'll be able
to select your loadout and drop into a
9v9 experience where teams battle to
hold control points with infinite
respawns another teaser within this
season's announcements are changes to
olympus this map has been out of
rotation during the last season and is
said to have something different
floating about the city so keep your
eyes peeled for that one and of course
there's gonna be a new ranked season and
a new battle pass coming to defiance as
well and if you haven't seen the news
stories from the outlands then be sure
to check it out we have it on our
channel right now
from software has completed development
on the long-awaited elden ring with a
master version being submitted for
approval work isn't completely done
though as the developers are now working
on a day one patch that will include
updates and optimizations producer
yasuhiro katau sub playtime will vary
depending on a number of factors but the
main route should take players around 30
hours as for the day one patch from
software didn't announce specifics about
what's included apart from that the
updates and optimizations are based on
the feedback from the network test and
that's not the only feedback that from
software has been acting on as all
online servers for the dark souls series
on pc have been taken offline due to an
exploit that can give an attacker access
to your entire system a dark souls 3
streamer by the name of the grim sleeper
streamed the exploit and took over his
own pc using a narration app to read out
some text to prove how easy it was to
control the system remotely this past
sunday it seems from software noticed
with a tweet indicating that all pvp
servers for the entirety of the dark
souls series would be taken offline on
pc as it investigates the exploit is
quite severe but it seems that the small
community that knows how to exploit it
hasn't chosen to do anything serious
with it and initially chose to report it
for fixing it's especially important
that it's getting fixed now too given
that the exploit was found in some data
mine code for ldin ring which is set to
launch next month
and for all the dead by day lightheads
out there the newest crossover event has
just been announced the horror game is
once again crossing over with the spooky
movie series saw with the villainous
killer jigsaw coming to the game
starting january 26th players will dig
into the memories of amanda young and
detective tap the expansion will also
add outfits for young and tap in
addition to 60 new cosmetic items the
saw content is being released in
partnership between developer behavior
interactive and movie studio lionsgate
this is just the latest saw crossover in
dead by daylight though as the first
took place back in 2018.
if you played the first saw crossover
for dead by daylight are you looking
forward to the next one if not what
other kind of crossover do you want to
see come to dvd let me know in the
comments below and of course leave a
like subscribe and come back tomorrow
for your next game spot news update